It’s daybreak in the city of Chan Chan,
and Maxo, a former soldier,
has been up all night fretting.
Last night, a friend stopped by and
instructed Maxo to go to the plaza
in the artisan neighborhood at noon
for an important message.
But with the recent political turmoil,
answering this mysterious summons
will be dangerous.
Situated on the north coast
of modern-day Peru,
for hundreds of years,
this adobe brick metropolis was
the seat of the Chimú Empire,
the most powerful empire ever seen
on this continent—
until now.
This morning, the sleeping city looks,
in many ways, the same as ever.
Its ten palaces have decorative walls that
keep ordinary people like Maxo out,
but he doesn’t need to enter
to know that the rulers inside
no longer truly represent his people.
Instead, the Incas rule here now,
after defeating the Chimú army.
They took the Chimú king, Minchancaman,
to the Inca capital of Cusco
and married him to an Inca princess.
Now, though one of Minchancaman’s sons
still sits on the throne,
he must do as the Incas wish
because his father is their hostage.
Maxo hurries past the palaces,
following a canal to his destination.
An elaborate network of canals
bring water from the Andean highlands
to this desert city.
The plaza is bustling, but to Maxo’s eyes,
it’s a shadow of what it used to be.
Before the conquest,
Chan Chan was a trade hub,
with llamas bringing goods
from the highlands,
and thousands of artisans—
including expert goldsmiths
and artists who turned the feathers
of macaws and exotic birds
into beautiful clothing.
All this is gone now:
the Incas took the artisans away to Cusco.
Inca spies could be anywhere,
so to blend in, Maxo approaches a man
peddling seafood.
As he barters for fresh fish,
a priest taps his shoulder.
He silently beckons Maxo to follow him.
As they wind through the empty
artisan’s homes,
Maxo fears a trap.
When the priest leads him
through a dark doorway,
he even draws his knife.
But when he sees what’s on the other side,
he drops it.
Gathered in front of him are influential
people from all over the city and beyond:
nobility, local political
and religious leaders,
even a few familiar faces from the army—
what’s left of it.
They've been secretly working on a plan
that could change everything.
Leaders from all over the
former Chimú Empire
are waiting to see what happens here,
in Chan Chan.
Tonight, they will rebel
against the Incas,
attacking the Inca soldiers posted
at the old fortress down the road,
site of the final battle in the war.
They want Maxo to join them.
Actually, they need Maxo to join them.
As the only survivor of the last battle,
he alone knows the layout of the site.
Maxo isn't sure he can face the place
where so many of his friends died.
And what about their king,
hostage in Cusco?
If they rebel,
won’t the Incas kill him?
In response, a young man steps
out of the shadows:
King Minchancaman’s son.
He explained that a rumor has arrived
from Cusco,
that the king is already dead.
So the time for rebellion is now,
and the young prince will lead it.
The prince’s speech is enough
to convince Maxo.
As he follows the canals home to prepare,
he remembers how the Incas
cut off the water supply,
but Chan Chan survived on its
deep, independent wells.
He hopes his city has one more reserve
of strength to draw from.
In 2016, the mummified remains of a man
from this period
were discovered just outside Chan Chan.
Many details of the rebellion
and who was behind it
remain mysteries and best guesses.
What we do know is that afterward,
the Incas burned Chan Chan,
killing many of its residents
and scattering others
throughout the Inca Empire.
Just decades later,
the Inca Empire itself fell,
conquered by Spanish forces.
As for our mummy, after surviving
many battle wounds,
he likely lived to an old age
and died of natural causes.